henri de la cruz es bombero entre sus
múltiples funciones hay una que jamás
hubiera deseado hace unas semanas tuvo
que dejar su moto y detener a un joven
que estaba a punto de saltar de un
puente y traté de
salvarlo porque él iba a haber éxito a
tirarse al vacío
y nosotros nos caímos en nacer
henry logró impedir un suicidio pero no
siempre es así el estado de mérida
registran 99 suicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes es el doble de la media de
venezuela thais beltrán sobrevivió a dos
intentos de suicidio tras el abandono de
su pareja llegó al límite ahora
participa en la ong somos donde trata de
ayudar a personas con pensamientos
suicidas
entonces el hecho de que uno tenga ese
pensamiento o tenga esos intentos hace
ver como que la familia se avergüenza de
ti como que es un tema que nadie va a
tocar las personas más propensas al
suicidio son colectivos vulnerables
también influye la situación económica y
la depresión las autoridades locales han
lanzado una campaña de prevención
necesitamos formar a la sociedad en este
tema hacer que las personas dejen de
pensar en esto como un tabú desde el
gobierno regional ofrecen asistencia
especializada y gratuita concienciando
sobre el suicidio y cómo prevenirlo
el objetivo revertir las estadísticas
del departamento con más suicidios de
venezuela'